LET'S SAY IN IN AWE CROWDED
ELEVATOR AND SOMEONE ASKS THE
GUY IN THE BACK WHAT FLOOR HE
WANT TO GET OFF ON AND ATTEMPT
AT DAD HUMOR LADIES LINKRY
IT'S AS OLD AS ELEVATORS
THEMSELVES AND NOT AS UP
LIFTING.
IMAGINE SOMEONE REGISTERING A
COMPLAINT AGAINST A MAN FOR
THAT JOKE DEMANDING JUSTICE.
THIS HAPPENED.
RICHARD NEDD LABOW LONDON
PROFESSION OR WAS AT A
CONFERENCE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND PACKED ELEVATOR HAD HE
MADE THAT SAME JOKE.
FEMALE PROFESSOR WAS THERE AND
FILED A COMPLAINT.
NOW, HE FACES DISCIPLINARY
CHARGES FOR WHAT SHE CALLS
MASSAGE ANY AND AN ACT I CALL
BITTER, SAD AND HUMORLESS.
DEFENDED PROP IS FROM WOMEN
AND GENDER STUDY WHO IS TO
REMOVE ANY ASEMBLANCE OF HUMOR
FROM THE UNIVERSE.
WITHOUT HUMOR EVEN LAME KIND
YOU CANNOT COMMUNICATE ONLY
LITIGATE, SMEAR AND PUPISH,
HUMOR IS DMZ BETWEEN PEOPLE
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE HATE EACH
OTHER HE DEFENDED HIMSELF
SAYING HE OPPOSES SEXISM IN
ALL FORMS THAT'S NEVER ENOUGH.
YOU MUST BEG.
INTERNATIONAL STUDIES
ASSOCIATION WHO HELD THE
CONVERSATION CONDEMNED HIM
CLAIMING HE VIOLATED THEIR
CODE OF CONDUCT.
THEY DEMAND UNEQUIVOCAL
APOLOGY WHICH I TRANSLATE AS
APOLOGIZE, QUIT YOUR JOB AND
LIVE THE REST OF YOUR LIFE IN
SHAME.
AS OF TODAY HE REFUSED.
GOOD FOR HIM.
CALL THIS "A HORRIFYING AND
CHILLING EXAMPLE OF POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS" HE'S ACTUALLY
WRONG IT'S A BAD JOKE AND